[Music]
Libya's disastrous floods this Tuesday
night but very close to 10 000 persons
reported missing the harrowing stories
of people swept out to sea and what's
interfering with recovery efforts Health
violations at a Calgary kitchen under
scrutiny food safety should not be an
educational experience for the people
working there at the expense of my child
climbing cases in the E coli outbreak
new testimony against the man accused of
murdering a Muslim family in Ontario
what a 911
and this security video revealed plus
Victory and Vindication facts when truth
wins Justice a Nobel prize-winning
journalist legal Triumph
thank you Rebel National with Donna
Friesen good evening and thanks for
joining us from an earthquake to
catastrophic flooding there are
disasters unfolding in two North African
countries tonight in Libya torrents of
water from Heavy Rain broke through two
aging dams about a quarter of the
coastal city of derna has been washed
away and in Morocco's High Atlas
Mountains where an earthquake collapsed
homes and entire Villages the window to
find survivors is closing in Libya it's
believed more than 5 000 people have
been killed and thousands more are
missing Swept Away by flood water that
exploded into neighborhoods with little
warning
this is during a downstream from the two
collapsed dams water is everywhere there
are harrowing stories of survivors
clinging to buildings more than a
thousand bodies have been recovered and
the number of dead is expected to soar
Libya has been mired in violence for
more than a decade infrastructure is in
bad shape and part of the country where
all this happened is ruled by a rebel
Coalition that's not recognized by the
International Community all of that
makes helping people difficult Redmond
Shannon has our top story tonight
storm Daniel dropped months of rain on
Northeastern Libya in just 24 hours
flooding entire towns the impact of
which is still unknown
but its aftermath is brutally clear in
derna the rainfall breached two dams up
River from the city triggering a wall of
water likened to a tsunami rushing
toward the sea instead of from the sea
it's possible that the upper Dam
collapsed first with a torrent of water
then taking out the second Dam and then
wiping out swathes of the city
destroying Bridges along the way the
affected Eastern region is controlled by
one of two competing governments in
Libya the prime minister of the
internationally recognized
Administration in Western Libya said
retrieving bodies swept into the sea
will be the most difficult task in
during our bodies that didn't reach the
sea lined the streets before lining Mass
Graves the final toll could be
staggering all over the five cities it
reaches up to or very close to 10 000
persons report
the government in the East says it's
using all its means to respond but
Libya's parallel administration's only
complicate Aid efforts the Prime
Minister Abdul Hamid Baba here in the
west cannot visit even visit the east
side because of politics political
analyst fauzi al-madani says he's not
surprised the dams collapsed given
Libya's years of conflict all the past
governments have done nothing right all
they've done is is Supply their military
interests of the different groups East
and West Libya for now at least United
in grief politics colliding this time
with a natural disaster yet another
painful chapter in Libya's turbulent
modern history Redmond Shannon Global
News London
in Morocco the death toll has reached
almost 3 000 after Friday's earthquake
we're still struggling to get to remote
villages in some places the wounded are
being airlifted out but hopes of finding
survivors are fading our crystal
commencing is on the ground in Morocco's
disaster Zone tonight
the unique skill set of experts search
and rescue teams is the difference
between life and death for people here
in Morocco four days have passed since
the most powerful earthquake to hit the
country in 100 years pulverized homes
and wiped out villages in the high Atlas
Mountains when I arrive this is how I
find my house
my neighbor house as well
that was in the house when I was growing
up it took foreign teams a while to get
approvals to enter the country getting
around to some of the remote locations
is treacherous our crew was held up
several times on the road there was a
small Landslide the roads are packed and
on one occasion traffic was halted as a
man on a stretcher was rolled across the
road to an ambulance
some aerial support is in use but more
is needed the lead of the United
Kingdom's special Rescue Team discussed
with Moroccan military officials about
moving some of his crew into place with
helicopters so they could get to work
quicker the longer we move away from the
F Center the the window slowly closes
but all the time that there is a chance
of finding someone alive will continue
to operate in the rescue phase time is a
factor and here there are many obstacles
a kind of a kind of buildings is very
difficult to rescue people and due to
materials it's very difficult to to to
find or the statistic to find people or
live people is very difficult for hours
The Rescuers their dogs and specialized
equipment sat idle it's unclear if local
officials didn't know where to send them
or if it was a a matter of accessibility
A new challenge here in the high Atlas
Mountains traffic it is absolutely
snarled right now and nothing is moving
we sat in the traffic queue for more
than an hour and walked up here to
discover it stretches right around the
road after waiting for several hours at
a base camp the Spanish search and
rescue team is just across the road they
haven't made it out today all this while
in villages and towns stories of
decaying smells intensifying some are
maintaining a level of optimism others
know they've lost loved ones because the
community did the work of sifting
through the rubble on their own one
thing is clear the number of dead is
likely to keep Rising it's nightfall and
we finally made it out of the mountains
we are now in the city known as the
gateway to the high Atlas Mountains the
entire trip down was Bumper to Bumper
the occasional raised voice and
sometimes emergency Sirens Donna
crystal gomancing in Morocco tonight
thanks
Alberta Health Services has revealed
troubling details about a kitchen shared
by a number of daycares in Calgary an
inspection found three critical
violations related to food handling and
pest control and the number of cases of
E coli related to Calgary daycares keeps
Rising there are now 264 lab confirmed
cases 25 children are in hospital 22 of
them have developed a serious blood and
kidney condition Sarah often on the
health violations and how parents are
reacting
it's been a slow difficult recovery for
this Calgary boy sick with a severe E
coli infection for the last week and a
half he's really weak and four-year-olds
when they're sick are cranky he went
into the hospital Saturday September 2nd
by 11 A.M Sunday doctors told them the
first of many tests was positive for E
coli the first communication from his
daycare came Sunday night with a warning
from Health officials about a
gastrointestinal Illness but it wasn't
until the Monday that Health officials
called it an E coli outbreak you're not
naming a specific bacteria that has
specific implications provincial Health
officials speaking publicly for the
first time since the outbreak we didn't
feel that there was urgency to do that
up until this point Alberta Health
Services releasing its latest health
inspections report following the closure
of the Central Kitchen believed to be
the source it lists five new violations
three of which are deemed critical
including ineffective sanitation
equipment called Foods being transported
to other locations in excess of 90
minutes without temperature control and
significant evidence of pest infestation
including more than 20 dead or alive
cockroaches around the dishwashing area
while almost a dozen food samples have
been tested the cause of the outbreak is
still unknown Sarah McDonald's boy and
21 others have been diagnosed with a
serious blood and kidney condition the
family is still unclear if there will be
long-term consequences for their son as
it calls for the Central Kitchen to face
consequences of its own the inspections
are first and foremost an educational
opportunity an education the kitchen
could have learned from after
remediating previous violations and a
response that's not sitting well with
parents now part of a class action
lawsuit food safety should not be an
educational experience for the people
working there at the expense of my child
I'll be making my kids food from now on
Sarah often Global News Calgary
Health Canada has approved an updated
moderna vaccine for covid-19 it's
authorized for use in people as young as
six months it's formulated to fight the
Omicron sub-variant that's circulating
right now but can be effective against
other variants too the vaccine is
expected to roll out in October updated
Shots by Pfizer biotech and novovax are
still under review there has been an
increase in coveted cases in Canada over
the past few weeks
Montreal police have launched an
investigation into so-called suicide
kits an Ontario man is accused of
selling 57-year-old Kenneth law was
arrested in Ontario in May investigators
believe he used a series of websites to
sell sodium nitrite a common
preservative that can be deadly in high
doses police in Montreal say they
suspect law sent sodium nitrite to
addresses in Montreal
it's not illegal to have this nitrate
sodium nitrate it's what we're
investigating is actually the the the
counseling or betting or aiding a person
to commit suicide so the people have no
worries in calling us and calling 9-1-1
if they believe they're in possession of
one of these kids
law is already facing 14 charges of
counseling and aiding suicide in Ontario
Police allege he operated several
websites selling items that can be used
for self-harm and ship them to people in
more than 40 countries in the UK
investigators have identified 272 people
who bought products from websites linked
to law 88 of them died
the jury in the murder trial of an
Ontario man has been shown surveillance
video of the accused moments after five
members of a Muslim family were run down
by a pickup truck four members of the
offsahl family were killed Nathaniel
veltman is seen dropping to his knees
and putting his hands on his head as
police race to the scene he's accused of
deliberately running down the family
with his truck in June of 2021. global
Sean O'Shea is covering this trial Sean
tell us more about that video
daughter we saw what appears to be the
first video of Nathaniel veltman in his
pickup truck just after that London
attack two years ago between that video
and a 9-1-1 call Feldman has heard not
only admitting what he did but asking to
be apprehended
two years after four family members were
out for an evening walk in London
Ontario the man accused of killing them
was back in court Tuesday
22 year old Nathaniel beltman arrived in
a prisoner van the subject of this
high-profile Terror trial prosecutors
argue veldman intentionally drove his
truck into the family because he wanted
to kill Muslims on the first day of the
trial they alleged development was a
white nationalist who left a hate-filled
Manifesto in his apartment they
introduced this security video from a
camera situated beside the Cherry Hill
Mall in London it shows a black Dodge
Ram pickup truck driven by veltman
entering the parking lot approaching a
yellow London taxi cab in court the
driver testified that feltman told him
to call 9-1-1 he asked me call the cops
call the police the taxi driver said
veldman insisted shut up call 9-1-1 he
ordered prosecutors played the 9-1-1
call
development could be heard making this
admission
insisting police come immediately
the driver says develman told him to
record what was happening he said make a
movie make a movie soon after several
police cars showed up develman dropped
to his knees his hands on his head the
taxi driver testified velpin was wearing
an army style helmet and a bulletproof
vest moments later develman is placed in
handcuffs taken into custody and
arrested defense lawyers have already
conceded Felton was behind the wheel
they haven't said what their defense
will be a jury trial is like a play
think of it as Shakespeare and they're
going to be three acts here there's a
crown that's act one is the crown
presents its case act two is the defense
presents its case if it chooses to and
act three is uh the charge to the jury
in the verdict so you just have to be
patient and the federal prosecutor said
they plan to introduce more admissions
from development including that he had
no regrets after the fact Donna all
right Sean O'Shea in Windsor Ontario
tonight thanks conservative MP Michael
Chong says closer cooperation with
Canadian allies is needed to combat
foreign interference by China
my experience is but one case of
beijing's interference in Canada many
many other cases go unreported and
unnoticed we can do a lot together to
counter uh this repression
Chong was testifying in Washington at a
bipartisan Committee of congressional
lawmakers he's been at the center of
foreign interference allegations in
Canada since reports surfaced the
Chinese government repeatedly targeted
him and his family Chong says Ottawa and
Washington need to increase transparency
to expose instances of intimidation by
beijing's agents and cooperate to better
track the transnational movement of
funds plunging popularity in the polls
coming up what's Weighing on the minds
of federal liberals as they gather for a
caucus retreat
the plane is fixed and prime minister
Justin Trudeau is on his way home from
India Trudeau and his son Xavier along
with the Canadian delegation left Delhi
this afternoon they were stranded for
two days after the G20 Summit because of
a technical problem with that government
aircraft the Prime Minister needed to
get back in time for a gathering of
liberal MPS they're holding a national
caucus Retreat this week and at the same
time are facing the worst polling
numbers since first forming government
in 2015. Mackenzie gray is in London
Ontario Mackenzie this is a prime
minister under pressure
yeah he's under a lot of pressure right
now Donna and he'll be hearing it from
MPS when he meets with them tomorrow you
know the Liberals are down 10 plus
points like you mentioned in the polls
right now the worst situation the Prime
Minister has been in for an extended
period of time and they really wanted to
refocus back in on housing the economy
affordability issues and that's what he
said he was going to do shuffling his
cabinet he did that seven weeks ago
we've seen no substantive new policies
from the Liberals right now but when we
talk to some MPS today they said maybe
they just need to refine their
Communications on what their economic
message is
the government does have a plan and it
has perhaps not shown yet all the
potential of its realization but it's
coming we are in solution mode we will
be coming up with key initiatives linked
to housing and Canadian can trust us
one of the most interesting things we
heard from was from Jennica Owen she's a
MP from New Brunswick she's saying at
the doors Donna she's hearing that the
prime minister is a part of a political
liability for the Liberals
I knock on Doris there's there's mixed
messages about how about our leader I
think sometimes it's also for people
thinking it's cool not to like our prime
minister right now which is a very weird
phenomenon that's happening
so McKenzie on another topic the federal
and Ontario governments are giving 28
billion dollars in subsidies to two
electric vehicle battery plants in
Ontario promising that it's good
investment in the economy what did the
Parliamentary budget officer have to say
about that today
yeah these deals down at 28 billion
dollars for stellantis and Volkswagen to
build those battery plants close to
where we are here in London St Thomas
Ontario and Windsor but the PPO said
that the purity of time that the
government had originally estimated in
particular the Volkswagen deal five
years the government originally said Mr
eugiru says it's going to take 20 years
for the government to break even on that
but despite that the minister who signed
those deals Francois Philippe champagne
says he'd do it over again
those are good deals for Canadians
because we're going to get our money
within a number of years and then we're
going to rip dividends For What 100
years
and it's no surprise to see the Liberals
supporting these deals Donna they're
really popular in this part of the
country and if the Liberals are going to
have a political comeback they know they
need votes in Southwestern Ontario okay
Mackenzie gray in London Ontario tonight
thanks
big Tech on trial ahead how Google is
accused of rigging the search engine
Market
[Music]
North Korea's leader got a red carpet
welcome in Russia Today
[Music]
Kim Jong-un rolled in on his pride
train and was greeted by a Russian
military Honor Guard he's expected to
meet Russian President Vladimir Putin
tomorrow the Kremlin says the two will
discuss bilateral relations the
situation in the region and in the
global Arena
the biggest Anti-Trust trial in decades
began today pitting the U.S government
against Google prosecutors claim Google
illegally abused its power rigging the
internet search Market in its favor
paying billions of dollars annually to
companies such as Apple and Samsung to
be their default search engine and
strangling competition Google denies
that it says its dominance is the result
of providing a better product than its
competitors the results of the case
could reshape how the public accesses
and interacts with the internet that's
being seen as a test case for how much
power U.S Regulators have over Tech
Giants a ruling is expected early next
year
Aerosmith fans don't want to miss a
thing but they will have to at least for
a little while
the band is post
about half a dozen dates on its farewell
tour including tonight's scheduled
concert in Toronto frontman Stephen
Tyler injured his vocal cords during a
performance in the U.S over the weekend
Tyler says the damage led to bleeding
and doctors say he can't sing for the
next 30 days six shows are now postponed
to early next year tonight's Toronto
show has been pushed ahead to February
21st 2024.
freedom of the press next a big legal
victory for Nobel prize winning
journalist Maria ressa
[Music]
Nobel prize winning journalist Maria
ressa has been acquitted in the last of
five tax evasion cases filed against her
in the Philippines and it's being viewed
as a win for press freedom
facts when proof wins Justice wins but I
think more important though you have to
really look at the impact on business
because the tax evasion charges
threatened the way of doing business in
the Philippines the acquittal now
[Music]
strengthens our resolve to continue with
the justice system to submit ourselves
to the court despite the political
harassment despite the attacks on press
freedom
ressa and her new side rappler faced a
barrage of civil and criminal cases when
former president Rodrigo duterte was in
power she believes they were politically
motivated an attempt to muzzle reporting
of the thousands of deaths under
duterte's anti-drug campaign they're now
being investigated by the international
criminal court as crimes against
humanity ressa won the Nobel Peace Prize
in 2021 for her fearless reporting in
the face of growing authoritarianism in
the Philippines an honor she shared with
Russian journalists Dmitry moratoff
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's hero
Canada is Western Canada's first steam
engine built almost 100 years ago in the
Winnipeg suburb of Transcona we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]